welcome everyone to the class Tuesday
night mastering the middle game and
we're going to go over one of my games
and I will kind of go through the
opening without spending too much time
on it because the class is on middle
game so and then we'll focus on the
middle game a little bit more one thing
I can tell you my opponent is a very
serious Grandmaster 2664 frisina and
this was played in a last round of the
national open big tournament in Las
Vegas so this is one of those games
where winner takes all so big big money
game because winner takes first prize so
a lot of the guys made short rows so
they didn't want to go for the first so
they just made quick draws and so this
this was a big game d4 d5 c4 e6 name of
the opening declined the client yes but
then he switches to c6
now let's change the name now it looks
like it's going to be a qgd but now it's
a different opening what is this called
same is love
same is love if there is a 6-pound we
call that a semi Slav if there is no c6
pound that's a pure Slav
so I played III I didn't feel like going
into this d takes e4 and b5 all this you
know by all you know all this you know
complicated variation so I figured I'll
just play easy 390 f3 Knight f6 so this
was very fashionable actually in 2009
this was very very fashionable this
system it just came out and guys like
Aronian some top-notch players they were
playing this and becoming more and more
fashionable I use this at the u.s.
championship 2009 a couple of games with
some good success there and so 2009 was
a you know pretty good year for me
actually I had a good showing at the US
Championship then you will say this game
turned out to be very well also which
helped me to win the tournament anyway
there was some good results overall
so this is still theory again I just can
kind of get to the main point here and
somewhere around here we are still in
the theory a little bit but from here on
let's say you don't know the theory here
let's say you just saw this position
first time in your life here and looking
at it what it's block trying to do here
what is the typical idea in this kind of
positions do you know block has two
plants in this position and that starts
about it if none of the plants would
work then he's just clearly worse in
this kind of structure where you have a
default punish this so how can you do
that
yeah excellent thinking yes so he wants
to play a six and c5 or he wants to play
e5 okay so now I play the move rook d1
which actually prevents both ideas c5
and e5 it stops it okay stop c5 and e5
so it was Queen b8 now it's trying to do
queen bee eight and now putting pressure
on H two H two pawn is under attack now
what to do with this pawn
huh make a lift
well let's think about it lift there are
other things we need to do first so
don't have time for lift okay lift is
the German word for air when you push
one of your pants this that's lost yeah
this loft creating the escape square
flight square you know that's what they
call it lifts its I think the most
proper way that they often use in the
books escape square you could say so no
but no time for loops here there are
more serious things needs to be done
another thing we have completed
development and Quimby it might look
strange to you but that's actually the
best move and this guy I'm playing
resume if you're not familiar with him
he actually was on 2008 he was the
second for for Vladimir Kramnik in a
World Championship match against Vishy
Anand so very serious theoretician he's
not just making moves here this guy's
analyzed this position but I've had a
good preparation myself in this line so
it was kind of interesting battle and I
think I I somehow yet think I got a
better gain that hit it here so what's
the move here I need you to play logical
yes absolutely absolutely you know if
what is your most natural move and
remember my concept usually the natural
moves are your best moves so you go for
it that gives you a threat everybody
sees the threat I assume if I've trying
to fork it trying to fork it yeah so he
has to do something to God so that's why
he had to do something so he played a
move e5 he has to do that that's a
typical way to stop it because otherwise
there is no no good reply so he played
here
now what to do here you need to make a
good move here this is not easy a moment
here to make a decision so let's I'm
going to give you time to think on this
because there are several moves you can
play here but which one would be the
best you're trying to obtain a small
opening advantage and try to improve
that opening advantage to more so what
move I'm talking about here
G take C correct he played Knight xe5
and now if you take if he just takes
back with the bishop and it's not it's
not totally clear very subtle move here
you have to make to create threats you
make this move and then suddenly you
have some threats Bishop f4 that loses a
piece Knight takes Knight check and then
he wrecks your Bishop so that's a
discovery yes Bishop f4 would have been
nice but if that King wasn't here then I
would have been excellent move but
unfortunately here that losses to
discovery who is going to be able to
find a subtle move here that will
without it no advantage we need that
move if you want to have some type of
advantage yes
g3 is a move that actually some other
grandmasters played in this position so
that's a very decent showing right there
but how about the best move g3 is not a
bad move actually computer probably
suggested g3 it's the top to move my
move is the first move but the other one
is not that GM's play g3 here
that's good move g3 shuts down the dark
square bishop that's the positive thing
about it King h1 no good night h4 a
little bit dangerous on the brim how
about this you know going to the side
you go to the center with that night
right remember night on the rim is dim
right why are we going there Danny why
here why not centralized centralization
remember we talked about that before now
what is the threat who is going to point
out a threat one two one two one two
remember that is a serious threat how
about this beautiful square for the
night to go - I think you might be
interested in that
getting the night out - so well of
course he knew this so he played them of
96 I wasn't very familiar with this move
at that time I had analyzed the move
Knight eg4 before so 96 he attacked my
pawn on h2 so now I need to protect it I
have two ways to do it
how you going to do it huh
well you have to protect upon either you
can play g3 or you can play h3 so the
best thing is g3 to shut down the bishop
I was rookie eight
now he is putting pressure now he is
starting to play B for attacking your
night and pick up the pawn so you have
to play it smart okay to defend against
a threat you don't want to allow this
okay you got to stop it yes better 83 he
will play a 5 so you got to do better
you got to do better it's better not to
start immediately defending you know
always remember defending yeah that's
the natural instinct it creates a threat
we start defending how about we try to
do some attack perhaps because you know
we can try to make him to get passive
right what else
nokton
No okay who's going to find the right
move here best defense is a good attack
are you trying to attack go
how about Bishop g5 developing the
bishop and creating a serious threat to
eliminate that night from f6 because
that's what you want to do you want to
eliminate that attack got it
was that where you will create
weaknesses cause Bishop to e5 he's
protecting it now if he had played this
move as a beautiful line you take he
takes
you take if he takes back 9f5 check
picks up the dishes so he takes you take
he takes double check checkmate
see how that works when your piece is
placed on the good squares and you're
paying proper chess good things going to
happen to you so you make sure you do
that put your pieces on good squares
okay don't do anything too unusual okay
every piece should be placed on a good
normal square nah goes here and he's got
some threads now he wants to take and
play some c5 ideas so what could be done
here what could be done here
yes
Knight to f5 MN Knight me belongs where
Martin in a Center on an active square 9
f3 again you playing retreat moves no go
active ok now you may think wait a
minute this loses a pawn no it's not if
it takes with this how about that C
always be on offense ok he takes no
problem no problem Knight h6 mate so if
it takes come in ok so what to do in
this position so he goes rookie 6 is
trying to play some defense moves now
what to do
this was very important move here to
make as his you know he's defending his
position and getting ready to such
questioning my bishop now what do you
think is the correct move here
absolutely for attacking that bishop
that bishop is a very powerful piece
what do you want to do to it move him
away if it takes on c3 again I just take
back with the Queen I'm happy there so
he retreats here now it looks my king is
exposed here and in particular this
point is now very vulnerable what are
you going to do now to defend this
vulnerable pawn push it risky risky
solidify the position first so now what
are you going to do now you got to
solidify the position yes
Bishop f3 first
he goes check
because before attacking you now he is
attacking your night and when you move
away there could be some danger here so
what are you going to do here
94 I wasn't so sure I could go 94 but
you need to do something better here 94
is a little bit weakening the position
maybe you can do something better to
reduce the tension there is too much
tension right now in the center I think
you might want a little bit reduce that
tension so of course we should take
subsea to reduce that and now 94 by the
way when they play before in this kind
of positions your 94 is the typical
square to go with the night okay so try
to remember that typical square to go is
a 4 because then you want to go to c5
now you played c5 and now you need to
make a decision what to do it looks like
he opened up his light square bishop and
there are some ideas for you here to
take the bishop on b6 but we don't want
to do that because he takes back with
the pawn if we take on c5 he has rook c6
ideas so we are not too sure what to do
rook d7 but then Bishop c6 I'm not sure
what you're going to do if I right away
check hmm oh yeah yeah check check
takes now this guy is hanging III g6 and
you lose the night and there might be
some consequences you might not lose
right away but it's not winning formats
for us yes smart in question you will I
don't know so but your idea is correct
that's the good news
so we will need to protect this guy we
need to protect this guy and with same
idea ok so how are we going to protect
and we got two ways to do it
Rock f1 or rook d3 ok Saiga Rukh f1
now protecting it nine goes Queenie
eight attacking this attacking this he's
trying to put some pressure now
do I have complete development here
specify which rock you think should come
on rook 81 he is thinking clearly
the last piece into the game is the rock
he should come in now I'm threatening
very powerful 96 attacking this
attacking that so he has to go here
Bishop c6 putting my knight on a four
now he's putting pressure here what are
you going to do specify specify take the
bishop this do we want to take this
bishop because he takes back with a pawn
he will have a good structure and then
his rook will be actively attacking you
you can also take this pawn but then it
goes through c8 okay
let's think let's gentlemen let's think
okay the most important thing is not to
rush okay whenever you're going to make
a move that you're rushing it might be a
mistake so take your time you don't have
to you know make decision right away
here so what is the right move here we
have three choices here Knight takes
pawn Knight takes bishop or b3 just to
protect it so which one is the right
decision in your opinion Martin and he's
got the correct answer
b3 with idea Knight B 294 see that's how
you master the middle game when you can
find good positional ideas in the middle
game like this that means you're slowly
mastering this part of the game
rook D it comes in now he is trying to
exchange the pair of the rooks what
you're going to say I know okay
your plan is to play e5 right and you
know my strategy when you choose a plan
you stick with the plan
let's go attacking the rook and
attacking the bishop he takes rook takes
see why I brought the rook here so I can
take with the rook now by playing g5
what I accomplished is I take away his
two bishops he no longer has that
advantage and he has a very how to say
not the best not the best looking bishop
here so to speak so here I probably
should have just gone boom put the
knight here and this would have been a
little cleaner but I played here which i
think is also not a bad looking move
centralizing and trying to obtain the
control of D file so he goes Queen e8
now
25 I suspect he might try to play the
move f6
I suspect that you know so that's why I
played them of 25 in anticipation of
that so I can go 96 okay so he was 97
trying to exchange that pair of the
night I take he takes and now what is
the plan correct
okay let's stop here all participants
today I want them to think a little bit
and each of you mentioned something
about this position okay you have three
minutes to think and tell me what are
the pluses and minuses you can see for
this position for white and tell me the
proper evaluation of this position is it
a small advantage big advantage for
white maybe it eco maybe it's even
winning so what is the evaluation here
let's take a good look at this position
because in order to find the right plan
you need to be able to evaluate the
position correctly so evaluation is very
important all right raise your hand who
wants to start
okay what's the evaluation first
question okay
Knight is dominating the bishop that's
correct d-file more space move the tree
okay so that's good what else you can
mention yeah block has weaknesses
correct c5 is weak light scores a week
that's strong here so white is better
who else wants to add there are a few
things you can add here actually one
very important thing you must add here
yes in the back ah yeah but let's
structural something structural you can
mention if 6 squared is weak could say
that yeah passed pawn well not quite a
passed pawn but yeah it's a good point
definitely but something fundamental you
must see here white King is exposed but
I have total total control here I have a
total control you cannot he can never
attack me here
so right now material looks eco correct
but is it really equal is it really
equal the material try to see where I'm
trying to go with this question that's
true he is very passive
we should be totally shut down we still
have to win it what I'm trying to tell
you is he has three pounds on the
queenside here right I have to let
thanks to my knight here versus bishop I
basically have an extra pawn on a king
side here because my pawns are mobile
they can moosh push forward but his
pawns are not so technically I'm playing
actually this game with the extra pawn
because the pawn on c5 or not doesn't
really change too much okay so that's
why my advantage is big here not small
because of that extra pawn that I have
you understand so now he played I pay
queen a Czech threatening to take the
pawn but Knight 8:28 if he had taken g7
out of gladly take the pawn but now it's
late here my question to you is what
you're going to do my question to you is
what you're going to do
yes I think if I prayed Queens are
basically walking into a draw what what
think you think well if you take the
pawn he goes Queen c6 and then I get
Lilia annoying actually because he peen
yo and I don't know if you realize your
queen is actually a little bit trapped
now on a seven that's not what he
mentioned f6 f6 is now coming very
quickly the Queen actually is going to
be in trouble here so this is very
important for you not to rush it okay so
that's why you don't want to play Queen
II a queen a seven but endgame actually
don't be afraid you're looking at the
material wise that's why you think it's
a draw but actually it's not now who is
going to get the D file here yes
so if it puts the rook in front of you
right that's a very simple way because
swap swap and you walk because you have
this nice entry with the king
okay so he cannot afford to do that so
it's going to go to key six now what are
you going to do rook d7 attacking the
bishop now goes rook c6 protecting it
and now what are you going to do you get
up - you get up - okay now he goes King
f8 King g4
now he attacks you
rock detail protecting protecting now he
goes here
I played rookie to second protective now
I need you to find a plan what is the
correct plan here excellent thinking h3
threatening to play g-force and now if
he played King g7 I was just going to
play g4 and f5 so it played f6 and while
I was thinking to play my next movie
actually resigned but let's try to
understand why he resigned the reasoning
okay
so I think this King can be improved a
little bit more right now I can actually
click this and take couple of pounds and
probably win but I wasn't going to do
that I just really enjoy my position
advantage here it's a static advantage
here I have so now I just want to play
what I'm stronger at what does that mean
where am i stronger here getting side so
let's push let's get some open files for
our rooks all rock it takes I take now
ready to go here if you move the way I'm
just going to take this with a check so
here let's say does something like this
group belongs here check check
it goes background mate check and you
just keep taking the pawns win the game
okay that's the reason he resigned after
the move f6 you know because then
position is just going to be difficult
g4 alright this was the victory against
Grandmaster frissina I want to bring one
example to your attention here and this
is a very interesting position again the
opening pay phase just finished here and
you have this position as white that
requires to play
very precisely if you want to have
anything here okay so we can say that
opening maybe didn't go quite well for
block okay yeah this is a cup of lanka
game Capablanca game against zoo but if
so this is the position so let's try to
understand what's going on here if it
was black to move black would instantly
castle and then he would actually have a
slightly better position because he's
got a good blockade then he will put the
knight on c6 rook 88 and pile up on it
and white white will be the one who
needs to find a way to secure a defense
and maybe make a job what can you do
here as white your white to move here
this is an opening stage just finished
and it was a successful opening stage
now you need to take control from here
on rook e1 absolutely now he plays f6
stopping your uki v he wants to simply
go king f7 tuck it in put the rukon e8
and say again i am the one who is
slightly better because you have the
isolated pawn what you're going to do
here how are you going to change things
around
yes
Queen a4 actually you're going to help
in go King f7y what do you want to go
King f7 anyway so check will actually
help me because I will go there and
bring my rook in yes better Queen e2
that's right
now you're threatening mate now he goes
Queen d7 just protects it the texts
check protects that again if you go
skiing if someone puts the knight on d5
guess what Bach is the one who is going
to be better here so you're actually one
move away from making one mistake here
and then he's gonna yeah he's going to
get a decent position in fact block
position is not that bad here he
actually just sort of misplayed it in a
little bit I mean it's it's it's still
risky but so now kappa blanka decided to
bring his best
you know his piece into the game rook c1
rook 81 was also very interesting with
idea to push now black plays his six he
wants to control that and then heat up
okay i go king f7 next move seasick turn
out to be innocuous he should have a
king f7 right away and you know it's not
a king at seven it's not so clear why
this may be a little bit better still
but he played this more c6 now now white
is that advantage of the development but
if you don't play this move now I will
put my king on f7 put my knight on d5
and I will enjoy the advantage so what
are you going to do
do we want to exchange Queens when we
are attacking
and here okay and yes but the problem is
now there's no attack anymore and I will
move my knight next and we'll swap the
rooks and it will it will be about about
equal because I mean you have a weakness
but I don't think black and black should
win this but but yeah you got to be
careful exchanging Queens because that's
not what you want to do here exchange
your Queens will reduce the material huh
Quincy for you can but maybe he'll go
long castle or something that's not out
of question you know better the player
with the advantage must attack mm-hmm if
he now hesitates his advantage will
demand diminish here now think about it
what can you try to do to try to open up
the position so you have some space okay
keep working hmm d5 CD which piece now
we'll have an excellent square to go to
there you go there you go that's how you
attack okay d5 threating these six ideas
or open up the position so he takes 94
perfect
superb square superb square for the
knight now he goes here again it's
trying to bring the pieces in so now you
must play this move what is the idea
excellent now you want to go rook c7
very powerful idea so he goes here to
defend against a threat now now good
move here you have activating your
pieces and creating threats think about
it thinking it true close there you go
do you see that you're threatening now
to take this pawn with the check and
then mate him on f8 that's a very
serious move okay so he has to play this
move to stop it and now this is the
beginning now how are you going to try
this combination now that is going to
check King here not so evidently not so
evident yet now
night what no no it's not hanging but
I'm not sure that's clear that line
Sakurako excellent now he cannot take
with the Queen because we just take on
c8 right that's that's clear we have to
make sure we understand why this is
losing because of the check now he has
to go let's say d8 check and discovery
check wins sure but what if it goes here
this now gets a little bit puzzling now
it's a little puzzling because you got
some background issues
can I get made it here don't rush don't
take anything you're going to get made
it now
Hey excellent
if it goes kill creation so he goes here
should be g8 you mean g7 or yeah check I
can't take with the Queen you take on
see it I can with King you think of this
seven so I have to do something so if I
go here then this check is nice here
Knight f6 here just check ok so it has
to go here and now
check
and now keep doing what you're doing
check again
there we go now now if you go see it 9 8
7 and take with check so it has to go
here and now
correct
if you go here you just take this and
it's made and now checkmate in three one
two three come on IAE in ninety six
Queen takes c6 and you got background
problems check correct f7 is better how
about that okay
calculation calculation that's what it
requires okay long calculation let's do
this again you are in command in this
position kappa blanka vs. subaru f 1925
moscow they just got out of the opening
block felt safe you know it Athena is
playing a world champion or future
champion so he's you know happy sort of
by one move that one move can change the
position the character of it so what's
the idea
show me the win keep going keep working
to go skiing F knocking afraid now nine
eight seven is good okay
beautiful
let's look like why he couldn't just
take back if he takes with a queen we
just go rook c8 win so if takes with
this what are you going to do check
check winning the Queen yeah so that's
why you couldn't just that okay all
right so that's a very very good example
of the game Capablanca versus abraeve
okay excellent
so very important this tells us you know
when we have initiative out of the
opening when we are just getting in that
middle game stage this is a good example
that you have to play energetically
especially if opponent King is in the
middle of the board you have to do
something to put pressure on it to
create threats okay and once you do that
then you're going to have a good
position so always remember to put
pressure if you want to win games put
pressure more pressure you put upon it
it's more likely he's going to make a
mistake okay so remember that to put the
pressure alright very good everyone